[Music]
welcome to I'm just gonna call this [ __ ]
conspiracy corner cuz I just made this
stuff right now if you do this in public
well no well no yeah it's Piercy corner
you could be doing group of mix-match
people that are interested in deeper
conversations get together and talk
about conspiracies baby no this [ __ ]
could be real or it could be fake or
could i don't know no i could just be a
lot of fun you know what i love about
having a specific format for it is that
when we bring it up a normal JK news
episodes if you just might bring it up
people like you believe in that [ __ ]
it's like no we just like to explore it
so this is a place where we can explore
argument very hard for things that I do
not care about I mean that's what you
learn a debate right is to argue for and
against something but yeah arguing for
things that you shouldn't argue for do
you ever get to that point where you
know you're wrong but you keep arguing
cuz you've been arguing so ya argue with
my wife thank you know today we're going
to talk about the Flat Earth and why
it's 100% real
and why it's not ridiculous and why the
government has been covering it up this
is not just the government the world
government seen that documentary on
Netflix about the Flat Earth community
yes I saw how they were portrayed I feel
exactly I felt like it was so biased so
it's like I got to hear out the other
side so I went and looked up all that
guy's videos that guy that they were
like following for the majority of it
like the leader guy I looked up all of
his YouTube videos first of all YouTube
really like covers them like his videos
were like it took a while I type in
exact titles and it was kind of like
covering them right it only makes it
sound like like Wyatt giving legitimacy
to the guy if you think that it's by
covering it anyway after watching all
the videos that documentary was dead
right but I wish they would have
presents it okay but those of you who
don't know what Flat Earth is right Flat
Earth is the idea that our entire world
is flat just like Columbus and all them
thought and basically there's like a
there's like a big ice wall at the end
of the edge of our circular earth right
our circular Flat Earth there's a giant
ice wall that keeps us from leaving
we're just a pancake like spinning
it's not a pancake it's like a good
there's like there's a globe right a
dome yeah and that's why you can fly
airplanes but if you notice airplanes
never go over the North or South Pole it
does no they don't actually know why cuz
a flight path or they determine them
unsafe in case of an emergency landing
that's what they say
right [ __ ] you go pretty darn cook
some when I was flying the first time
wind when you go to it's very close
yeah Japan to I went to Sweden was for
someone went out of the country and I
was looking at those some of the lady
was like to me she was like why is it
that we're like flying over Canada we
should just go straight like that I'm
like oh that's because the the earth you
know because it's a globe it's faster
travel if you go on the smallest you
know trajectory which is Li know if
you're on the the poles it's a shorter
distance than if you try to go around
the equator right so it's like that's
the reason why we're going up that's why
it looks like we're good we're doing
this curvature because well that the
world is cursed and so like whatever I
like it here flutter Thor vol like tell
that like no no it's oh but then the
North Pole is actually in the middle so
it's flat so they can go over the North
Pole but then the South Pole they don't
because that's the key or yes I never
traveled south so I can why don't we go
from Portland to Japan right over the
[ __ ] top of the globe if it's a
[ __ ] globe well some people say that
we do but they don't show you that on
the flight pattern they not freak you
out that you're over ice like how did it
take such a short amount of time and
people are like this cuz we went this
way it stood it Doug can you Maginot
sigelei beat out the window to your left
is the North [ __ ] Pole that's so
gangster dude I'll be so sick so what
about when I go on Google Earth and then
you go back
it's composites it's a composite image
so it's you actually like people have
zoomed in and they're that you can't get
an entire picture of the globe there's
like pieces where it's a copy pasted
hmmm to be around because it's composite
images so it there's spots where it
misses what about what you could do live
feeds on the satellite camera and it
it's going around yeah so it goes around
like
can't fit the whole earth in it I don't
know what about what about the times
like like the the amount of sunlight
that you get because I think in
wintertime up up north from us yeah the
Sun is a lot longer yeah because the
axis changes so then yeah we're not
actually perfectly aligned we're
actually at built the flat earthers
explain that
don't deny any tilt they just deny that
that were an orb so like there's still
like a plane and it can still tilt I
don't know where they think that where
we are though right like where is the
plane rescues it in space speeding
around us right I mean we orbit around
you think it's like a light like it goes
up like that yeah like it's part of like
the inner filaments that like it's like
a like a mobile like a little say they
believe the Sun orbits around Earth yes
earth or you'll have that I'm gonna tell
ya they think that the Sun is a
construct yeah like a stage ladies why
would the world government or anyone go
to the link is a [ __ ] difference
between a sphere and a flat but if the
Sun is an orbit the moon or if you look
either presence their orbs those are all
those are all on or off this guy's would
follow the [ __ ] money you could
actually unravel this conspiracy that so
big globs like do you like to think
about everything every classroom when
you're growing up there's a glow so
those guys are rich crushing it dude you
had a quite big Atlas out of business
yeah because know the big Atlas come for
the big globe business businesses would
be [ __ ] man you have to owns YouTube
who is suppressing the flat-earthers
who Google Google Earth Google Earth
they don't want all the money follow the
money but what about NASA so there's a
religious sect that thinks that the orb
thing is so that people believe more in
science than religion and like they want
everyone like the world wants everybody
to think that they're insignificant so
that they don't like there's no way that
science and religion could ever
no the idea though is that if the more
that you understand about our world
through science the more you understand
how small all of us are and how
insignificant we are whereas the part of
the Flat Earth movement is about how
special we're special that's all I don't
and sick that's a stupid we are all sick
we all type we are all doing no isos to
because only like some of us are special
yep no that's totally true that's
doesn't believe in the flattery special
they're very special you know what even
though you don't you you might not like
how the way that I think that I like the
way that you think is that true speaking
of that I recently heard of this thing
in Scandinavian culture called gentle
lovin or Santa love gentle yeah this
wing okay I probably didn't see it right
but it's it's like gentle lovin or some
[ __ ] like that only not even heard it
okay
so I read this [ __ ] right I gotta pull
this up okay but it's basically it's
it's in there they preach this in their
culture and and I've noticed that
Swedish people are like really [ __ ]
sweet and humble and nice and so it's
like a it's kind of taught in school at
an early age and there's these rules to
kind of live by and and you know how
we're just talking about we all think
we're special that's an American thing
yeah right yeah I like yeah we're like
you you're so special you're unique and
all this [ __ ] right so here's the 10
steps to [ __ ] gentle love inch and
gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen gentlemen
number one you're not to think you are
anything special you're not to think you
are as good as we are
number three Yuri I think the community
oh you're not to think you are smarter
than we are
number four you're not to imagine
yourself better than we are is this
communism number five you're not to
think you know more than we do this is
just reverse Mister Rogers
number six you're not to think you are
more important than we are number seven
you're not to think you are good at
anything
number eight you're not to laugh at us
no dad not to think anyone cares about
you not to think you can teach us
anything dude in Russia this is what mr.
Rogers told ya like some [ __ ] ten
steps to be depressed yeah that's why
the obviously because I do you have so
opposite to American culture is and but
I actually do think that we do put too
much pieces like gods everyone's special
whatever everybody what everybody you
could be a president everybody you can
be like the best thing it's like staring
Lane go to trade school yeah there's
nothing wrong with but we we grew we we
raised some crazy egotistical narcissist
right in America because of this lack of
humility and humble well that started in
the 80s I was reading a study how like
they were doing Studies on on kids and
how they ended up in different career
fields so like how did CEOs end up being
CEOs and like how come some people get
successful some people don't and it came
down to like they're like Oh self-esteem
and self-confidence in childhood is a
big factor in to whether or not they
become successful so when their minds
are like what if we start teaching the
kids at a very young age that everyone
is special everyone had like build their
self-esteem early and then they hadn't
seen the repercussions of it until now
and so now we're starting to see like
that people are like kind of becoming
apathetic and indifferent to like
complacent because they don't see the
difference between true success and like
a fake success so it's very interesting
because like back before then like the
Depression era all of that there was
still like your work hard to keep your
head down there wasn't like a lot of
your special your special your special
but then the kids that were raised like
throughout the 90s and stuff they
started implementing but everybody gets
a participation award and then my dad
really hated participation Awards it's
[ __ ] stupid like as a kid I was like
why I got a trophy he's like no it's
done
that's got a dumpling someone lets you
win yeah I didn't like no satisfaction
in that no work there's no overcoming I
thought that's what can you work advert
what it really is what's that Einstein
quote where he says like if you try to
teach it or tell a fish that you can't
climb a tree you're dumb like you like I
think it's about everyone has different
kinds of intellect or different kinds of
talents yeah and that's see that's my
whole thing too is that like I don't
think everybody need to be a [ __ ]
astronaut no oh you could be an
astronaut lawyer you probably don't want
to be like some of this stuff [ __ ]
sucks like yeah I know you probably does
everyone wanna be a CEO it's yeah it's
like there's only a very few amount of
people that have that kind of [ __ ]
like narcissism or whatever that can
function in that environment lui because
and it's a lot to do also when like
people get weird think emotions are weak
because they're like there's such an
emphasis on logic and math and science
being smart and like that's the smart
those are the smart fields where if you
like let's say have high emotional
intelligence and you're really good at
you know helping other people like
things like that yeah it's valued very
low when you're in school maybe later
you could take psych psychology and like
explore that field but like in school
they're very like math science logic
logic they're very easy to like your
grade you know kind of like a breakdown
and stuff they can control you that way
because I mean I think they're dumb and
then they go oh I can't ever be
successful in if you're a kid right now
and you think that all Steve means full
of [ __ ] cuz he believes in Flat Earth
hundred percent but please if I try
going try this experiment go to your
teacher tomorrow tell them that you show
them a picture of the earth or of the
map that you have in your classroom tell
them that it's complete horseshit you
think it's [ __ ]
guess what happens next you go to the
principal's office why do you go to the
principal's office for reprogramming so
they can get back under there you think
okay you're still listen to me you're
like secrets [ __ ] you think because
a hundred percent believes in Flat Earth
theory okay guess what try opening a map
store try opening on all in the next
door you're not gonna be in business for
very okay whoa yeah
it's the hardest thing to do right now
is open up an almanac store the kid that
actually goes through with this and then
they they don't send in the principal's
office and then his whole worldview just
explodes that's the reason why it's hard
not that there's the internet opening a
map for it try opening at all a
Christian bookstore has more opportunity
than a freaking Maps exactly because big
because big almanacs and big clubs will
crush you they will [ __ ] crush you
out of existence big Almanac excuse me
who is big Almanac nobody knows okay big
globe man that's my favorite and
conspiracy time hey if you do this toss
in public and you wink like this we'll
know what you mean
[Music]